paul nicolas menut patronale écoliers
qu'est ce qu'il y a pas preneur
[Musique]
people1 jeunes s'habillent et oui ça se
voit recevoir les enfants au froid on se
croit ce que je suis content patron nous
sommes très heureux de revenir vous voir
savez-vous qui nous avons rencontré
pendant notre voyage
gentil petit chinois qui s'appelle
viande chute et il va donner quelque
chose pour pas prodl eu nicolas je vais
vite que leur portent plus dépêche-toi
nounours ils sont sûrement impatient de
voir hop ou le cheval
[Musique]
voilà mon et shan
l'eau
je descende revoir
nicolas mas preneur
je vais leur dire bonsoir
[Musique]
j'ouvre la fenêtre
tre montre son bruit je crois qu'ils ont
honte d'être tous deux surpris
oh les coups quand ils m'ont bien qu ils
sont déjà couche
voilà voilà
bonsoir les zoos
qu'est ce que tu me fais apporté un beau
cadeau que donc juju m'a remis pour nous
de pippo des pipots que notre gentil
petit chinois a fabriqué pour vous avec
les paons bout de son jardin une somme
au alors souffler dedans
bien sûr comme ça maintenant et nous
[Musique]
c'est pour brouillon c'est pas brillant
j'ai lu deux le téléphone voilà et one
000 ici on patron
on voudrait bien savoir comment il faut
un pour jouer du pipeau
c'est très simple il faut commencer par
faire do ré mi fa sol la si et d'eau
c'est ce qu'on appelle une gamme comme
ceci est maintenant il faut faire dodo
car il est tard demain nous jouerons au
clair de la lune
bonne nuit oh mercy pas trop à tout de
suite
bonne nuit de noce viendra vite demain
raga musique je produis le vent en eau
[Musique]
on crée ni sol et la doré miss à me
connaître
ceux-là si l'un prône l bonne nuit les
petits enfants je suis sûr que bientôt
vous nous ferez la surprise de jouer de
très jolis their aux pipots allons en
route nounours on route au trop grand et
nuit elle de borel à demain peut être de
pauvres
[Musique]
o o